hello everybody the February charity
livestream is going on right now if
you're seeing this video then we're
still rolling so please click on the
link in the description below to be
taken over to my twitch page also in the
description is a link directly to the
new GoFundMe page which is the charity
raising service set I'll be using from
now on because chip-in is shutting down
and apparently GoFundMe is actually
quite a bit more versatile but anyway we
are raising money for the Cancer
Research Institute which funds
immunology research efforts which is a
pretty big I don't know if you're any of
you have read the recent news stories
but there's been some good breakthroughs
in immunology or using the immune system
to fight cancer which is pretty good I
mean all of us have been affected by
cancer in one way or another I mean
everyone here watching this could name
at least one family member that has died
from cancer and a scary thought is that
you know but quite a lot a high
percentage I think it's about 30% of
everyone watching this will have some
form of cancer down the road it's
extremely prevalent relevant or
prevalent or whatever the word is it's
extremely common more common than people
realize I mean it may be down the road
it may be a young but it affects a huge
number of people so please stop by the
stream give generously anything you can
can help and there's a new page where we
can keep track of all the donations and
you guys can actually see who has
donated so that's a much better feature
so thank you all so much for helping out
please stop by stay as long as you can
donate whatever you can or just show
your support by sharing this video or
the GoFundMe page itself so thank you
again and as always I will see you at
the live stream bye-bye